[Music]
gaines would like a game i think it's
only fair to grant him that
and by the way kavita anybody who
is a consistent supporter would like a
speedrun game i generally accommodated
c4 english defense
now
there are many ways
to face the english defense
since we play the queen's gambit
declined against d4 in the speed run
let's play e6 and those of you who play
the queen's gamut decline as your main
opening this is how you want to meet c4
you don't even really have to study it
separately because e6
virtually guarantees
a transition into queen's gamut decline
because you're gonna play d5 on the next
move
make sense so d4 d5 and we have
transposed into queen's game declined
now you don't have to play e6 of course
the principled move is e5 and that leads
to the reverse sicilian structure which
um which has been
very extensively studied and which
you've seen in my blitz games
okay knight c3 thousand bits from
proceed thank you
okay knight f6 let's play it
traditionally
let's play the traditional queen's
gambit declined
bishop g5 and now those of you
who have paid particularly careful
attention know that i like a tricky move
knight b to d7 which
is the main line and it also sets a trap
like i've told you guys i've seen
very good players fall into this trap
and that trap happens after cded knight
takes d5 that loses a piece and i'll
show that after the game one more time
but take my word for it queen c2
already i think inaccurate
already inaccurate um and we we have
multiple ways that well not really an
act queen c2 is okay
but i think the better more accurate way
of playing is either e3 or knight f3
focusing on development
when i see the move queen c2 the first
thing i notice is that it leaves the d4
pawn unattended
and
if you know anything about these queen
scam decline structures you'll know that
one of black's main ideas in such
positions is to do what
and we're going to play this move here
it's a very principled move
it's a little bit more aggressive than
how we've handled these positions in the
speed run but we're going to give it a
shot yeah the move is c5 creating the
pawn square
and hopefully everybody can see the
drawback of queen c2 which is that i
mean we're threatening c takes d4
and more importantly if white plays d
takes c5 we are not just gonna passively
recapture
what would we have done in response to d
take c5
what would we have done
again exploiting the drawback of queen
c2 we would have played d4 we would have
advanced our pawn to d4
exactly rook d1
now here we want to play much in the
same vein right the fact that gains gain
senses that d4 needs to be defended but
he doesn't defend it with the right
piece the rook is not a good defender
how should we proceed
how should we proceed
so a lot of you guys are thinking okay
let's reinforce the attack on the d4
pawn
but that's not the approach that i would
take here what i would say is we can
take d4
we force the rook onto d4
and then we can attack that rook while
developing our other pieces
and as you'll see that actually leads to
okay never mind knight
whoa
knight b5
that's actually probably the best move
which is kind of funny
i think rook takes d4 would have landed
white in serious trouble
okay now
now we got to be very careful
uh what what should you notice when you
look at this position well one thing you
should notice is the c7 square
right you have to be very careful not to
leave that square unattended
if you play queen a5 check here which i
know entices some of you then after
bishop d2
black is in a bit of trouble we can't
really take a2 because then we have a
loud knight c7 check right
so the best approach here is a different
development move and some of you have
named it i like bishop before developing
the bishop with check
essentially forcing white's bishop back
to d2
okay now we have another choice this is
a very complex position actually as it
turned out turns out
we can do several different things here
we can do several different things here
um
so some of you are proposing a5 which i
understand the appeal of that
but after bishop takes a takes
notice that white will have knight d6
check i don't want to allow that check
so we can take the bishop
first of all we can take the bishop
uh but the other thing that we can do
is drop this bishop back let's say just
to e7
then essentially say that we have gotten
white's bishop onto a very awkward
square
right we can play bishop b7 and then we
can castle and perhaps that's not the
absolute most that we can squeeze out of
the position but it's something
but it's something but if we're already
playing bishop e7 if we're already
deciding to move the bishop back
what how should we do it what is the
nicest square for the bishop along this
diagonal
now if we're already moving the bishop
back we might as well make it harder for
white to recapture d4 right is that
logical so let's play bishop c5
let's play bishop c5 and at least let's
try to harass him a little bit knight f3
okay
so
now the approach should be the following
what i want you guys to see is that the
king is out of squares that's the first
thing that i notice when i look at this
position is that the king is out of
squares
okay
the second thing that i notice is that
i'm noticing mating patterns on f2
so for instance if we had a knight on e4
and
the pawn disappeared from d4 we would be
threatening checkmate so immediately i'm
thinking of and we're gonna play the
move knight e4
which believe it or not indirectly
defends against knight b takes d4 what
will we do if gaines takes on d4 with a
knight
and this is not unlikely to happen
not not entirely unlikely
we will go e5 we will go e5 chase the
knight away
and white will end up losing that knight
because he can't move it he'll get
checkmated on f2
now again i'm not explaining everything
super clearly here i'm expecting some of
you to be confused
this is just a complicated position
there's no way around it so i won't be
able to capture absolutely everything
but i'm doing my best
b4 excellent move though by gains
excellent move
and this forces us to move our bishop
yeah a lot of you see d3
which we could consider but after d3
white plays e takes d3
although no we can play d3 no no we can
play d3 i i missed a detail there that i
just saw
spicy game for sure
queen d3 bishop f2 is checkmate
so white basically has to play
okay well
that's unfortunate but i'm gonna go
ahead and check madam
whoops
all right gaines i mean you're already
in trouble here
but i actually think white is in a lot
in much better shape than people realize
after he takes d3
so this was tunnel vision right this is
tunnel vision i think you spotted the
queen and again if i may be so forward i
think the reason this happens is still
fear of your queen being attacked
and this is something to work on for
everybody like below 1300 it's like
when your opponent attacks your queen
the first thing you need to do is not
panic the second
thing you need to do is to remind
yourself not to tunnel vision that
attack to see what else your opponent's
move does
right he takes d3 is the move bishop
takes f2 king e2
and this is actually a interesting
scenario the knight is hanging and if we
simply move the knight then we lose the
bishop
so
what does black have to do here
what does black have to do here
knight takes d2 exactly
okay but here
white can recapture with the queen
now the bishop is hanging we have to
move it we should probably move it back
to b6
and now what kind of moves can white
make here who can propose a nice move
here for white
no it's okay i mean you actually played
not so badly in the opening this is
interesting let's analyze your knight d6
check
now this move is not that scary for
black because white white's pieces are
so passive
that uh a move like king f8 is totally
fine for black it's not like black king
is in any danger here notice that
black's king is in no danger at all in
f8
but the game goes on i mean queen f4 is
an attempt
although black can simply block the mate
threat with queen f6 and ultimately
black is up upon here white's king is in
shambles so we are much better but the
game goes on
the game goes i know b4 was very good it
was really the only move
but there's a lot to unpack in the first
couple of moves so
first of all the trap
is of course and i'm sure everybody
knows this knight takes they might have
shown this before
okay i don't like the phrase everybody
knows it because
you know i know some of you don't but
and that's okay
but black plays knight takes d5
oh blunders the queen no it doesn't
bishop b4 check this trap exists in many
different variations by the way not just
here it exists it exists across the
board
white is forced to play queen d2
and when the smoke clears black is up a
piece actually my brother caught at 1500
on this trap so
something to file away
um
but games queen c2 is inaccurate because
you leave the d4 pawn unattended
and the clinical move here for white is
e3 the theoretical move i should say is
e3
e3 and then quickly developing your
pieces i have nothing to apologize for
you gave us a lot to analyze and then
quickly developing the king side
this is mainline theory
after queen c2 c5 the situation gets
very spicy
now i'm sure that there is some theory
here so
you guys especially youtube people can
run stockfish and probably stalkers will
laugh at me but i think c5 is a very
unpleasant move to face
now who can tell me what the most solid
way of defending d4 is
what is the most solid way of defending
this pawn
and generally when i say solid and
defense in the same sentence you should
be thinking i want to defend a pawn with
another pawn right defending a pawn with
another pawn is going to guarantee
at least a decently solid position and
so i think e3 is the wisest move here
i think e3 is the wisest move
c d e d and
white is okay white is okay this
potentially would will reach an iqp
structure i mean if life plays dc this
is an isolated queen pawn structure
which is totally fine for white
in fact we've probably transposed into
some sort of a nimzo indian type
structure
i would not have taken on c4 in one fell
swoop though we would have probably gone
bishop p7
and waited for white to move the bishop
to take on c4 you know that trick you
wait for white to develop the light
square bishop so that you make him lose
a tempo
um
but it's a game
and i see that five games continued
bishop e7 here straight away so some
people didn't even take on d4
white is totally fine here does that
make sense rook d1 is a conceptual
mistake
defending the pawn with the rook
is rarely a good idea
and gaines i'm sure you saw that after
rook takes d4 black already has tactics
black already has tactics yeah the
position is pretty much equal there what
should black do
so bishop c5
rook moves back and those of you with a
keen tactical eye should immediately
spot a very very nasty tactical pattern
bishop takes f2 this is as old as the
hills knight g4 queen takes g5
knight is coming to e3 this is a
particularly bad version of walking into
this tactic
this is crap
so after bishop z5 it's already major
trouble for white
um and so i think knight b5 is very good
games i think this is a great move
and here things get quite complicated so
you can definitely analyze this with an
engine and i'm sure i didn't play this
accurately
but bishop b4 was an intuitive move just
developing with tempo bishop d2
and now a lot of you were proposing a5
but
okay takes takes knight t6 is one thing
that it allows although simply king e7
and black is fine
although simply king e7 and black is
black is more than fine white is
completely undeveloped here
but uh it's
white also can kind of ignore this and
play knight takes d4
right so a5 is is one possibility
but another possibility for black is to
trade on d2
and then
well the first takes d2 maybe 94 is the
most ambitious approach
so there's multiple ways to play this
but after bishop c5 i was hoping that
you wouldn't find this gains and you
didn't
and this is a bit of an opportunistic
move how should white continue here and
the first thing you should think about
is getting this bishop away from c5
so that you can take d4 and restore
material equality b4 is correct
now here we would have done bishop e7
and inducing before i think in this
particular instance favors black
why is that conceptually because i think
white is so undeveloped
and so potentially overextended
that pushing out further pawns creates
more weaknesses that are easier to
attack if that makes sense
but but after knight takes d4
we would have castled you can play e3
and you you're starting to stabilize the
position
quickly developing the king side pieces
and i think white is still fine
by playing knight f3 and procrastinating
with this you allowed knight e4 and now
it's kind of too late to take the pawn
because of e5
and if you try c takes d5 last question
for you guys what should black do here
should we take on d4 immediately or
should we throw something in first
you know not stupid i mean this is what
you should do you just did it in a
slightly inferior version
knight takes d2 first very important and
then we take the knight
and yeah it's unfortunately you
blundered here but
it's also a very very tense position and
it happens
and i think your main mistake really was
was actually rook d1 i think this is
where
uh you know the crap hit the fan after c
takes d4 because this here it got very
very hard to play for white
so one of the takeaways here is that
defending upon with another pawn is the
most solid way of
defending anything of the pawn is the
most solid way of doing that so there's
an inverse relationship between peace
value
and its ability to defend another piece
not necessarily intuitive you think let
me defend it with a queen
but again the queen is the worst
defender of other pieces because
precisely because it is the most
valuable piece because it's vulnerable
if you think about it it starts making
sense
okay
um short game but i think there was a
lot a lot there to unpack so hopefully
you enjoyed gains thank you for all the
subs and the support kavita you got dibs
on the next speed run
but if that's if it's okay i'm gonna go
to bed because i'm exhausted and uh
tomorrow's another day of commentary so
nine a.m tomorrow for rapid
day two
actually not day two just rapid playoffs
it's gonna be a fun one aronia nakamura
it's gonna be close i think they might
even go down a blitz so definitely don't
want to miss it i'm gonna rate canty
guys i'm gonna read canty thank you so
much for the support good stream today
and hopefully see you tomorrow thanks
for hanging out good night everybody see
you see you in the morning
[Music]